بعت يوم قال الكاتب والمؤلف البريطاني
جورج اورويل ما من احد امسك بزمام السلطه
وهو ينوي تخلي عنها مره اخرى ويبدو انها
خطه دونالد ترامب في العوده الى الرئاسه
رغم القضايا التي تلاحقه تعكس واقعيه هذه
الحاله بدقه كبيره ترامب رفضها هزيمه 2020
ترك البيت الابيض على وقعت فوضى اعمال
الشغب العاني ففي حادثه الكابيتل وهذه
عقبه ثالث امامه واليوم هو السبب في
الانقسام الجمهوري بعد انتخابات النصفيه
شكل فيها انكار وفوز بايدا اختباراتا
اساسيا للمرشحين
الجمهوريين بتاييد ودعم ترامب السياسيه
الاداء او بالاحرى النتائج كانت اقل من
التوقعات لاكتساحا احمر وان حصلوا على
اكثريه مجلس النواب لكنها كانت طفيفه
بينما عدد كبير من متبنيين نظريه تزوير
الانتخابات 2020 المدع احنا عملنا ترامب
غسلوه في الولايات الرئيسيه لكنه شهيه
ترامب اللي كسب جوله الرئاسيه جديده وشعله
الشعبيه الشعبيه اقوى من ان تطفئها معارك
صغيره خاسره لازال كما يقول البعض انه
الوحيد القادر على مواجهته يسار عنيد وادي
كلي
رز
[تصفيق]
لمرحله المجابهه هلا سيرشح الجمهوريون من
يعرف الديمقراطيون انهم يستطيعون هزيمته
هذه روايه الاخرى تقول ان الديمقراطيين
يلعبون على اسقاط ترامب من الداخل كيف
يضعفون سيطرته على الحزب ويسلطون الاضواء
والاعلام على مرشح الجمهوريه للرئاسه
والعهد